this is what we organized temporarily
this is just one of the dozens and
dozens of refugee shelters being set up
in warsaw
a welcome camp bed after the bunkers and
the bombs and the days of travel
i love you
i love you they long to be home
but family after family tells of the
trauma of escaping war
julia struggled to reach kiev train
station with her daughter who has
epilepsy and her son who's autistic
what can i say she says it was so hard
trying to hold my children's hands in
case they fell and carry the luggage
[Applause]
then she reveals eleven-year-old nikita
is recovering from an operation after
being born with deformed feet she got
here guiding one of her children who's
barely able to walk
others at the shelter need medical help
a young girl is on a drip dehydrated
after the exhaustion of the journey to
poland
now made by a million and a half people
so the problem now because so many
refugees have come to the polish capital
because the authorities are so stretched
they're having to provide more permanent
accommodation or boss people to other
polish cities
this refugee crisis is defined as an
exodus of women and children
across the city there are makeshift
nurseries to entertain the youngsters
and women distraught they've left
husbands brothers and fathers behind in
ukraine
anna's left her husband in kiev she also
has to contend with a mother-in-law in
russia who refuses to accept why she's
fled to poland
she said oh it's just a
little not big not big situation it's
just a little he said mom we had no
house russians destroy our house
across poland thousands of people who
needed no persuasion of the horrors of
this war are taking in refugees
english teacher victor johnson and his
wife offered a home to marta and her
grandchildren
both of the children's parents are still
in ukraine i didn't speak to marta
before she came here she just turned up
in the car
and so we met them with
high fives and hugs
invited them in made them feel at home
and
that was the most important thing that
they felt safe secure
we asked roman how he's settling in all
things considered
okay okay nice
just one example of the kindness of
strangers in the midst of war lisa
holland sky news warsaw